hallo zusammen willkommen zum Q&A von
der Reportage Atomstrom Auslaufmodell
oder grüne Lösung in der Energiekrise es
sind viel interessante Fragen vor ihnen
[Musik]
zum Auffangen möchte ich ein Videocall
machen mit der Christina Marschall sie
ist unabhängige Energieexpertin und ich
würde sie mit das BAföG aufbrachte
Themen konfrontieren
[Musik]
zum Thema
Preis und Kosten vom nuklearstrom und
das hat mich später pro fit mohammed hat
geschrieben AKWs
betrachtet und auch welche Typen
und ich denke die bestehenden AKWs
solange sie sicher sind weiter zu
betreiben das ist jetzt derzeit eine
sehr günstige Abstrom zu gewinnen
in Neubau von AKW hängt natürlich auch
sehr davon ab wie sich jetzt die
Technologie weiterentwickelt es scheint
derzeit eher ein teureren Strom zu gehen
also da wäre Wind und Solarstrom derzeit
im Neubau günstiger also als ein neues
Atomkraftwerk
Sicherheitsdefizit wenn man jetzt noch
verlängerer wird ich denke wir können es
bis 2034 schaffen
unser Erneuerbaren so aufzurüsten dass
wir den die AKW abstellen können aber
ich würde auch dann zu dem Zeitpunkt
wieder beurteilen wie weit sind wir mit
dem Klimaschutz müssten wir dann Atom
oder können wir vielleicht auch Nachbarn
unterstützen mit unserem Strom die noch
mehr fossile im Strommix haben erst wenn
wir auch unsere Nachbarländer als alle
geschafft haben den dreckigen
kohlegarten Bildschirm abzustellen erst
dann würde ich die AKW runterfahren
natürlich immer unter der Voraussetzung
dass das alle Kontrollen ergeben dass
sie derzeit sicher betrieben werden
können es gibt natürlich Länder wo es
ganz klar ist dass das nicht die nicht
so hohe Sicherheitsanforderungen haben
wie in der Schweiz und da ist ich sage
nicht dass Atomkraft nicht auch gewisse
Risiken hat also das ist ein GAU geben
kann ich wäge einfach derzeit wirklich
ab dieses gigantische Risiko des
Klimawandels im Vergleich und auch und
das sind reversible Prozesse ihrer
versive Prozesse beim Klimawandel die
wir dann irgendwann einfach nicht mehr
stoppen können und das bewegt mich
eigentlich zu sagen dann lieber den doch
das etwas geringe Risiko dass wir da
beim Atomkraft haben ich habe zum einen
Protagonisten aus der Reportage nochmal
Kontakt kann wiederkommentarisch
innerhalb
[Musik]
welchen Vorschlag haben die beiden
Herren um unseren Strom zu produzieren
gerade
diese Bitte gleitet und er hat
geschrieben die Zukunft ist erneuerbar
und dezentral es hat genügend Flächen um
Solarenergie zu gewinnen gratis und ohne
macht Energiezentrale sicher und sauber
kurz die AKWs helfen uns nicht in der
Zukunft zu risikoreich und zu teuer und
der Atommüll ist noch immer nicht gelöst
der nächste Kommentar und von Markus
bonachs schon eine falsche Information
gleich zu Beginn die Schweiz hat kein
Ablaufdatum für Kernkraftwerke
festgelegt die Anlagen dürfen solange
weiter betrieben werden wie sie den
Sicherheitsanforderungen genügen gerade
vielleicht anhand von Beispiel vom AKW
göst geantworte stimmt was der Markus
schreibt sie hat unlimitiert die Lizenz
allerdings muss man sagen dass die
Akkusativ erbaut wurde sind mit der
retour mit der geschätzten
könnt mir das auch länger Betrieb also
zum Beispiel 80er und das werdet ihr nur
prüfe aber es ist so dass man die
bestehende Akkus irgendwann mühend
abstellen zum einen wird ewig ist und
zum anderen will man es ja politisch
entschieden haben dass man bis 2050
Datum Umstieg umgesetzt hat der wittere
Frage ist dirty soweit ich weiß werden
die jetzt bekannten Uran vorkommen bei
jetzigem Verbrauch nicht mal mehr
hundert Jahre reichen das allein müsste
doch ein ko-argument sein ich muss sagen
das mit deiner 100 Jahre Uran vorkommen
habe ich auch klasse ich weiß aber auch
dass alles
Reportage
sind aber epitieren neue Thorium
Reaktoren wo das ganze ist anders
Ausgangsmaterial buchen zudem Schritten
andere User Kommentare der Hans Dieter
jung frankreich hat den ersten
Fusionsreaktor im Bau geradeaus
recherchiert die Bauarbeiter
Technologie werdet Atomkern fusioniert
anstatt gespalten und dort wird aber
auch kein uranpunkt in weitere
kommentarisch
Atommüll Endlager wird nicht behandelt
genau das wäre es interessante XI mit
Atomkraftwerk kann ich wenigeres Problem
aber so langfrage mit der abfallanlösung
nun erklärt ist ist es einfach nicht der
alternative also muss er den Punkt sagen
wie ernst Thema Anlage zumindest
Ausschnitte zum einen wo sag jetzt das
ist das Problem ist und wenn sie es muss
wieder bauen mit Shisha wissen was sie
mit dem Abfall machen und das eben nicht
der Fall ist aber auch der Herbert
Meinecke war seit das sind die brandstab
noch eine ist Anlage können mit
irgendwann wenn es baut wird und dass
man eben mit dem brandstapel Recycling
quintis Atommüll Problem verkleinern
zum einen der Standorts
fest von der Medien ausgeschlachtet
wurdetler unter anderer spektrisch wie
groß muss dann so eine Anlage sie und
wie viel Platz werden wir haben und das
von der Kubikmeter seit Nagra werden wir
buchen aber es Anlage wird ja 86000
Kubikmeter baut der größte Teil ist aber
nicht schwer radioaktives Material wie
brennstabs sondern Licht und Mittel
aktivs Material wo zum Beispiel beim
Rückbau von einem AKW muss abbaut werden
und dann in das anlagergrund Drum auch
die Größe vor dem anlager aber da könnte
man zum Beispiel noch eine neue
Reportage machen wenn es dann baut wird
also wenn ihr Wand dass ich es Anlagen
kann
wo unter anderem
schreibt super Reportage allerdings muss
man bemerken es werden die Meinungen der
Experten AKW und Lion Greenpeace und
Aktivisten verglichen man sollte mit
Paypal Experten auch reden mit
Protagonisten und Protagonistinnen rund
ums Thema AKW ausgewählt und das haben
wir uns entschieden so mit dem Peter
schulertreter wo ja unter anderem eine
50 Jahre aktivistisch sondern auch
architektisch mit dem Fokus auf
erneuerbare Energie und vor allem
Solarinstallationen und auch Coach ist
auf Energie und zum anderen wo
Greenpeace Activision ist und
stellvertretend für Organisation redet
wo sich schon Jahrzehnte mit Atom schon
befasst ich kann jetzt aber noch ein
Videocall mit dem kitchen Schaffner er
ist Energieexperte von ETH Zürich und
ich werde in einer Folge was er findet
ob aquaves grüne Technologie und ob
solar- und vor allem auch die
Solaranlage könntet der Atomstrom
ersetzen
[Musik]
wenn man CO2-Emissionen anläuft also
Klimagasemissionen oder Emissionen
relevant sind dann ist natürlich keine
Energie eine von der besten Technologie
will pro produziert die Kilowattstunden
am wenigsten oder ja mit Abstand hat
wenigsten CO2 mit dir erzählt natürlich
muss man sehen dass wenn wir jetzt
Nachhaltigkeit Alu Akten andere
Kriterium mit ihnen spielen zum Beispiel
Anlagerung
Atommüll auf deutsch gesagt das muss man
sicher mit ihnen bereiten auch oder wie
man das als Gesellschaft gesehen haben
technologisch ist das lösbar machen
Atomen Abfall ihr verlagert dass sie
auch sicher sind aber ob mir das als
Gesellschaft
die Kritik oft erneuerbare Energien ist
eben dass sie nicht so ausbaufähig ist
dass sie jetzt die Vollvertrag von
momentan hat mit AKWs könnte zudem ist
ja Zukunft wird viel mehr elektrifiziert
mit buchemehl Strom sehen Sie das
realistisch dass die erneuerbare Energie
in die Schweiz könnt das ersetze und
Ausbau für Zukunft was mich an aufzeige
ist dass es möglich ist absolut mit vor
allem großen Zuschauer im Bereich
Photovoltaik sondern Energie der Therme
große Potenzial in der Schweiz zum
wohllaufdächer als auch auf anderen
Infrastrukturen als auch potenziell
sogar intern
aber natürlich ist es richtig auch noch
2050 und was man denn noch erwartet ist
extrem wichtig dass man wenn eine neue
Technologie
Technologien marktbringe das wird
Weitblick gesehen also dann widerspricht
sich das nicht oder was man jetzt
kurzfristig mehr mache ist insbesondere
aus der Erneuerbaren Gier Photovoltaik
und Wien in der Schweiz aber natürlich
auch alles andere
das Wasserkraft und dann gilt sie dir
aber auch weiter damit man weiß wo sie
in Zukunft contego
so ich hoffe wir sind jetzt fest
erschlagen von der Thematik ich bin es
ehrlich gesagt